- Guten Tag! Fromme mein Name. Sind Sie
die Veranstalterin des Flohmarkts?
- Ja, die bin ich.
- Ich bin vom Lokalteil des Tageblatts.
Darf ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen stellen?
- Klar, gerne.
- Wie sind Sie auf die Idee
für den Flohmarkt gekommen?
- Ganz einfach. Man kann nicht immer
alles neu kaufen. Hier wird recycelt.
Gebrauchte Gegenstände werden hier nicht
weggeworfen, sie wechseln den Besitzer.
- Das Besondere hier ist ja, dass alles
umsonst ist. Warum?
- Wenn Sie etwas wegwerfen, bekommen Sie
doch auch kein Geld dafür, oder?
- Das hier ist doch toll!
- Das hier find' ich schöner.
- Frau González?
- Entschuldigung,
was wollten Sie noch wissen?